in lockdown
the prime minister
bush johnson he just went down
to a party in lockdown in lockdown
he's really naughty now so we have to go
to the naughty center and tell everybody
that he's sorry for going to a party in
lockdown
points i was trying to put across to
former conservative minister and
whitaking just before the break laila
did it far better than i did and
whitaking for uh the prime minister
laila will find out the somali joy
family join me now from their home in
leicester good afternoon to you great to
see you here on sky news
um your video has gone viral it's been
seen by thousands of people and tell me
what do you think the prime minister did
wrong
what did he do wrong
he he went to a party in lockdown
well there's an inquiry going on uh to
find out all about that party layla i'll
ask you did you stick to the rules
during lockdown did you go to any
parties
yeah
yeah yeah a very good girl no need for
you to go to the naughty centers and the
prime minister did say sorry
yesterday for going to a party um do you
accept his apology layla
did you accept his apology
do you forgive him
yeah
yeah you think it's important to say
sorry what do you think should happen
now leila what do you think should
happen to him i think
i think he should leave
you think he should leave
and why is that layla yeah
because she's
been
naughty
look at the camera he's been naughty and
nitesh and davina how did layla get so
caught up in the world of politics how
does she know so much about what's going
on
in government
well in in the mornings we always have
the news on when she's having breakfast
and um
it's it's always one in the background
so i think that morning we just had it
on and she just went running into the
kitchen and she's like she goes to um my
mother-in-law that um
she just starts coming out with it so me
and nathan stop what we're doing and
we're like what is she saying
so then my father-in-law came down a few
minutes later and um she started
repeating it so we quickly just grabbed
our phones and recorded her um and we
didn't expect it to grab this much
attention
no yeah she said it to my mum first and
then i thought it was really funny so i
went and grabbed my phone and you said
it's your granddad didn't you did you
say it to him yeah what did you say to
him
in lockdown the prime minister
um went to a privacy
in lockdown
yeah and then what happened
he had to go to the naughty center and
what did he do
what did he do
he told everybody that he's sorry yes
that's right he told everybody sorry
yeah
can you do anything to change your mind
leila if you're not going to accept his
apology
did you accept his did you say did you
say you forgive him earlier why did you
say you forgive him earlier
what was your reason
do you remember
oh
that's right yes
earlier she said she gave him because he
gave everybody injections on which arm
layla
did they did he give him injections and
he kept everyone safe
yeah do you like boris
oh there you go so he's wider record uh
is making up for um him going to a party
leila and
what's it like now that you can see your
friends and you could go to parties
later because it must have been hard not
seeing friends and family during
lockdown
what's it like now
sing everybody
is it fun
did you have a fifth birthday party yeah
yeah how was that
good yeah did you enjoy it yeah yeah
and how was your fourth birthday party
what was that one
was it zoo was it one zoom was it really
yeah why was it on zoom
because it was locked out yeah and you
were not allowed to do what to do in
long time locked down
um
you didn't you didn't get to see your
sister did you for a long time no no
yeah
are you allowed to have parties do you
long town
are you latter parties no leila
so angry with the prime minister in
terms of having her fourth birthday on
zoom while the prime minister had his
party but leila i understand you've got
a joke to end with tell us your joke
yeah go on tell me jay um why does
um
the prime minister like the queen i
don't know why does the prime minister
like the queen
because
she
likes the doors on her crown
he likes the jewels on her crown
layla i very much like that really good
to talk to you i'm glad you've forgiven
the prime minister will other people it
remains to be seen